[Music]
if you like well-written animated films
with hard humour and great action
actually scratch that if you are
currently or have ever been alive then
you probably love The Incredibles
experience a film that's got a little
bit of everything from Silver Age comic
book heroes to a dark snapshot of a
dying marriage slick retro James Bond
style to a portrait of a midlife crisis
the warm glow of familial love to the
soul-crushing modern-day workplace once
again you'll pay Pixar to yank your
heart around like an emotional yo-yo
meet the poor's an incredibly
dysfunctional family violet is neglected
- is hurting people for fun Bob is
sneaking around behind his wife's back
and Helens in denial about his obvious
lies have a great trip
sweetie they've got more issues than a
comic book shop and the only way to
resolve him is to put on spandex and
beat the crap out of some robots
together
in Giroud world where the government has
banned superheroes for fairly obvious
reasons you knock down a building now
Bob will have to adjust and not being
able to punch people for a living until
he leaves in an opportunity to work for
a killer robot company with a volcano
lair dude you were a hero for like
decades you didn't see any red flags
here I'm starting to think this guy just
wants to hurt people with no
consequences hey heroes don't do that
unless you're Batman Batman totally does
that cower before one of the best super
villains of all time syndrome a perfect
prediction of today's entitled fan
culture he's a nerd who loves something
so much than when it didn't live up to
his expectations we're not affiliated
with man he declared war on it and now
only The Incredibles can stop him from
letting me buy rocket boots I'll sell my
invention so that everyone can be
superheroes well that's just great now
how am I supposed to become a hero
toxic waste covered reptiles aren't
cheap you know enjoy the best Fantastic
Four movie never made that fixes on the
Fox from those awful awful films having
it's for Heroes feel like a real family
not treating their powers like a joke
and making it so mr. fantastic is
married to the thing which is way hotter
I mean better I mean damn it they're
just both so thick so cheer up Logan and
turn that frown upside down Rorschach
cuz The Incredibles proves you don't
have to be r-rated to be a violent
angsty superhero movie with a super high
body count attempted suicide heroes
threatening to murder innocent people
it'll be easy like breaking a toothpick
grown man shooting at little kids and
little kids killing grown men
[Music]
you wonder with me Brad bird flying to a
homicidal rage between the Iron Giant in
this movie probably box-office money
money money money money story honk he'll
stretch arms mob Nick flurry phony stark
Dick silver violet you're turning violet
violet the Epcot Center grown-up Stewie
do you find something comical about my
appearance and I'm driving my automobile
[Music]
this is fantastic 40
so that okay Brad that Edna goes on nut
cakes were those her designs that got
all those heroes killed before she
learned her lesson because whoo that's
dark
neither rain nor snow nor sleet nor
laryngitis shall keep the epic voice
from his appointed rounds
continue talking Meg it's muffin time
people say nothing is impossible but I
do nothing every day get these denim
snakes of this denim plain